rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message don't
take things personally over to you Bill
Gates you have four years ever since you
were a little boy I have been called a
nerd do you care does it hurt you
well nerd means a lot of things I'm
somebody who can sit and read a book
about science for hours on end and you
know I don't mind being labeled as
somebody who who finds that interesting
there is hardly a day in which something
is not written about Microsoft it has
become almost a frenzy you're being
called the evil empire you forget being
called a nerd you are now being called
arrogant greedy the devil who read all
this stuff I heard that this has been
said what do you say about all of this
well it's a very competitive business
and I don't know absolutely when you
have the level of success that we've had
when you have a business that's
important as this with this many
competitors you're going to have people
saying some nasty things and so you have
to learn a little bit not to take it too
personally if you're doing something big
you're gonna get haters if you're doing
something that nobody has done before
that is game-changing that is breaking
the status quo you're gonna have people
who want to hold on to the Past want to
hold on to their way of thinking they
don't want to see other people become
successful and so they're gonna hate on
you the more you're off being bold and
trying to do something different
creative new could be on it on a global
level or could just be doing something
that's not normal in your family right
then you're gonna have haters you're
gonna have the people who are against it
because they stand for the status quo
the more you stand for something big you
understand that you stand against
something else and the people who like
that stuff even if it's a negative way
of life they're gonna
for it and I'm gonna see you as the
enemy and attack you what's the
alternative the alternative is to live
such a small life to never take any
risks
to only do what everybody else tells you
to do never have a life of your own so
that you don't risk offending everybody
that's a pretty crappy life and it's not
that you're out there intentionally
trying to hurt people it's not saying
look at me and how great I am and you
suck right it's not it's not putting
that kind of vibe out but just by you
being you and trying to do something big
and bold it's gonna upset people not
because they actually hit you it's
because they hate something within
themselves I look at my message and
believe it's powerful it's positive it's
uplifting how do you hate on believe how
do you hate on somebody who's
encouraging people to untap their
potential right but people do I think it
takes some getting used to and I think
that the more you are out there the more
content you're creating the bigger your
company grows and the bigger that you
get and the more of an audience that you
build up of customers or people
following you then the more you're gonna
be seen as a target for a certain select
group of people and I used to in the
early days of me have my youtube channel
I used to take it personally I used to
be really upset when somebody left a
negative comment I used to you know only
see that one negative comment and ignore
the 99 positive ones I used to try to
fight with that person and explain
myself or try to change them and try to
bring them around and in that process
sometimes at work sometimes I was able
to explain my perspective and bring them
around to my point of view or at least
get some kind of common ground and
sometimes it did sometimes I couldn't
change them the thing is it just takes
so much time and effort like is it worth
spending all that time on that one
person you're trying to make a positive
impact with a navy ship in a little bit
versus investing that time into the 99
other people who love you who care about
you who were really consuming that you
can go a lot further with and it sounds
crass and it sounds it sounds really
terrible to say don't spend time on
those people ignore them but the fact is
they steal so much of your energy and
it's always an opportunity class like
that time spent if I can help 20 people
achieve amazing results or try to help
one person achieve subpar results that's
just
better than what they were getting
before what's the best use of my time
and so that was one thing that really
helped me shift away from trying to
fight with them from trying to change
them and just leave them leave them
there leave those comments up but it
still hurt right like it still hurt like
god stings that comment the thing that
really shifted it forward for me of not
caring of putting things in perspective
was me trying to put myself in their
shoes imagine somebody who's who's gets
off by going to a YouTube channel or
going to a customer site or going to an
e-commerce site or whatever it is and
leaving a negative comment even like a
hateful negative comment not not a
constructive criticism nada Evan you
know your hoodie is off today you know
get the lint roller or something right
like constructive criticism just just
nasty hate stuff what would motivate
somebody to do that
like imagine that that this is how they
get up this is how they are half like
how crappy a life do you have to have
that this is the thing that makes you
come alive feel happy and just by
shifting that perspective now when I see
negative comment like that it also just
makes me feel sorry for that person that
this is the only way they get attention
this is this is the best part of their
days the highlight is be able to come in
the hate comments their entire life must
really suck and that shift allows me not
to care because it's easy to say well
don't care don't pay attention to the
haters and it doesn't mean you have to
engage with them but it can still hurt
that comment now I try to look at well
who is this person was leaving hate on
me if I'm feeling sorry for them it's
hard to it's hard to still feel the
sting when you can sorry for something
if the summer that you feel sorry for
says something negative at least for me
it's hard for me to actually digest it
to feel like it's anywhere remotely true
because I looked at their life to say
this person has a really crappy life and
I don't want anything to do with them
you know I don't want to be around them
if they're gonna be spewing that kind of
hate and so I found that that really
helps and so for those of you who might
be afraid of doing something big because
you're afraid of haters you're afraid of
negativity you're afraid of controversy
you're afraid of ruffle a few feathers
understand that you serve nobody by
playing small
and you can't let a vocal few minority
people prevent you from going off and
doing something great and when you see
do see those negative reviews you do you
see that that personal hatred or
criticism just try to put yourself in
their shoes ask yourself what kind of
life is this person to have that this is
this is their highlights that come and
criticize me and if you feel sorry for
them at least for me it takes the sting
out of the comment so the question today
you know I'm gonna make it a challenge
of the day the challenge of the day
today were switching tonight things up
we're switching things up the challenge
of the day you know how much a positive
comment can mean to people I know when I
first started my channel seeing every
positive comment one comment on the
video just made my dad Wow somebody's
paying attention I want to challenge you
to find a YouTube creator or or somebody
on social media somebody who you've been
following you get some value from who
doesn't get a lot of engagement who
doesn't get a lot of comments and just
say thank you just let them know that
that their content what they're doing
their mission is inspiring to you and is
helping you just give them that little
comment because it helped me so much in
my business and I mean it still does I
love you guys love some other comments
come in but for the person who gets
almost nothing that one comment makes a
difference and so I want you to be that
person for somebody else that's my
challenge of the day today we're gonna
we're gonna combat the negativity and in
the comments here I want you to share
who that person is that you're gonna
leave a comment or I maybe give them a
little bit more exposure as well you
know bye you're committing it you're
committing to it you're gonna write it
down and then everybody else watching
and maybe go follow that person or it's
spread some love as well so where we're
putting out the positive vibes instead
of the negative ones so leave that down
below and then go make the comment on
that person's channel I also want to
give a quick shout out to Guillermo
mounteen dad thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word really really really means a lot to
me and I hope you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
this prey so give me go
you got to get some haters you need
haters no school is gonna teach you how
to get a hater okay high school
elementary school colleges what do they
teach you want to be the most popular
person no you want haters okay the
companies that are hated are the
companies that are exploding the people
that are hated are the people that
explode if I don't hate you if nobody
hates you nobody knows you so the reason
I'll tweet for instance when we started
we had this that newsletter that I sent
out okay we send it out every week we
were hitting people once a month and we
started getting complaints you send
stuff out too much my office came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have more people pulling off of the
newsletter good double up again why I
want haters okay so we start sending out
one every week and then I started
Twitter account I actually had people
write grant cardone
social media people grant cardone is an
example of what not to do with social
media
I said freaking just multiply just
increase it okay we were doing like four
tweets a day good do to an hour why
because I want my competition hating my
guts someone I'm talking about me I mean
I don't really want hate people to hate
me you understand what I'm saying about
I want them so so energized did they
actually start pushing me they start
promoting me you did a routine recently
about how women like it rough and then
of course the internet police got all
over you
well I gotta be honest - I didn't notice
if that happened because I don't pay
attention to it
I don't let's rewind yeah they hated you
yeah but who did like 40 people like 20
people with the hashtag can get like a
news story going now and I just I just
don't think there's no problem like the
amount of time somebody tells a joke and
they'll say that there's a controversy
at a comedy club that's funny as they'll
show the clip on the news and like you
hear the crowd laughing so the comic is
basically guilty of telling a joke that
worked right you know what I mean
and then if you put it on the news yeah
it's gonna be a completely different
context but I mean I don't go on stage
and worry about what people are thinking
I mean if you you know you you can
choose to take a comedian seriously but
that doesn't mean that I now meant the
joke and you can start saying that this
statements you know the last thing I
need to do is go you know form rolling
and checking out what the people are
talking about me and like I don't care I
don't care and and I'm you know a part
of me wants to to to like ask them like
what's wrong man like why are you like
why why am i mine should I not be
allowed to do this I'm not doing
anything wrong
I'm not I'm not you know killing babies
or you know I'm not doing anything bad
like you don't have to like my music but
do you have to put any other side of me
is like that you know it's a waste of
time but I mean I matang Gris sometimes
but then you that kind of washes away
and then you just go man that's suck I'm
more interested like when I read things
and message boards and reviews like I
want to hear good I want to find out new
cool things I want to hear the new great
song I don't to hear someone
trash-talking someone else I'm not just
that's not discovering it that's that's
dictation you know what I mean I'm not
discovered you're telling me to think a
certain way or as like something more
open minded like it's gonna make me want
to grow raise your standard
and not one drop of myself work depends
on your acceptance of me I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details